Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Before we get started today, this was supposed to be our big announcement of our first live show in a year. It's on the 13th of November in London. But we released the tickets early to our club members and they've pretty much sold out. Now, it is still possible to join the waiting list. The link is in the episode notes where you can search The Rest Is History Live. So as I said, this was going to be our only live show in 2022.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。在今天开始之前，这本应是我们一年来首次现场演出的重大公告。演出定于11月13日在伦敦举行。但我们提前向俱乐部会员发布了门票，目前几乎已售罄。现在，您仍然可以加入候补名单。链接在剧集说明中，您可以在那里搜索“The Rest Is History Live”。正如我所说，这本应是我们2022年唯一的一场现场演出。
So we're very sorry if you've missed out. And if you don't want to miss out in the future, you can always join the club at restishistorypod.com, restishistorypod.com. But we're going to try and work out if there's something else we can do. We're going to see if we can work out some other arrangements or maybe one extra show or we'll see when we come. Yeah, exactly.
所以，如果您错过了，我们深表歉意。如果您不想在未来错过机会，您可以随时在 restishistorypod.com 加入俱乐部。但我们会尝试看看还能做些什么。我们会看看能否做出其他安排，或者增加一场演出，到时候再看。是的，没错。
But I'll keep you posted on that. And in the meantime, even if you don't want to join the Rest Is History Club, other arrangements or maybe one extra show or we'll see when we come yeah exactly but i'll keep you posted on that and in the meantime if even if you don't want to join the rest is history club just keep listening hello and welcome to the rest is History's Love Island. The couples are on their way to the island bronzed, buffed, stripped and ready. Yes, it is that time of the year again and if you're wondering what I'm talking about, don't ask me because this is not my idea. I'm here with my co-presenter Tom Holland who reveals himself to be an unexpected reality TV show enthusiast. So Tom, what is Love Island and why are we doing it? I don't really know because I've never watched it. Oh no. But we are a podcast, are we not, that responds to great public events. So we've responded to
我会随时向大家通报最新情况。在此期间，即使您不想加入《历史的余味》俱乐部，也请继续收听。大家好，欢迎来到《历史的余味》版《恋爱岛》（Love Island）。情侣们正在前往岛屿的路上，晒得古铜色、身材健美、衣着清凉，准备就绪。是的，又到了每年的这个时候。如果您想知道我在说什么，别问我，因为这不是我的主意。我和我的联合主持人汤姆·霍兰德（Tom Holland）在一起，他竟然是一个意想不到的真人秀节目爱好者。那么汤姆，什么是《恋爱岛》，我们为什么要录这一期？我真的不知道，因为我从来没看过。噢，不。但我们是一个回应重大公共事件的播客，不是吗？所以我们回应过
political events, to sporting events, to all kinds of occasions yeah and there is no question that here in britain love island um is a big event we are obviously both kind of 273 so it completely passes us by however i have two daughters and you may remember that last year my younger daughter eliza persuaded us to do a version of love island on our episode on henry vi's Six Wives. One by Anne Boleyn. Yeah, one by Anne Boleyn, who absolutely iconic contestant. And so this time around, I thought it would be good. We'll do a whole episode themed around Love Island, but because I've never watched it and I don't really know how it works.
政治事件、体育赛事以及各种场合。是的，毫无疑问，在英国，《恋爱岛》是一个大事件。我们显然都属于那种“273”的人，所以它完全与我们擦肩而过。不过，我有两个女儿，您可能还记得去年我的小女儿伊丽莎（Eliza）说服我们在关于亨利八世六位王后的剧集中做了一个《恋爱岛》版本。其中一位是安妮·博林（Anne Boleyn）。是的，安妮·博林，绝对是标志性的参赛者。所以这一次，我想如果能做一期以《恋爱岛》为主题的完整剧集会很好，但因为我从来没看过，也不知道它是怎么运作的。
Tom, your research has let you down completely. No, but I have an elder daughter who is on hand and is at the end of this microphone. So a great, great thrill to welcome to the podcast, But I have an elder daughter who is on hand and is at the end of this microphone. So a great, great thrill to welcome to the podcast my elder daughter, Katie. Welcome to The Restless History. Thank you so much for having me. It's been a childhood dream. So Katie, just for the benefit of the many British listeners and the many overseas listeners who may have no idea what Love Island is can you just give us a very very brief sketch about what it what it involves of course um so it's been going on now I believe for six seasons um and essentially um Love Island is where you get a group of very good looking people onto an island in Mallorca
汤姆，你的研究做得太不到位了。不，但我有一个大女儿在场，她就在麦克风的另一端。所以，非常非常激动地欢迎我的大女儿凯蒂（Katie）来到播客。欢迎来到《历史的余味》。非常感谢邀请我。这简直是童年的梦想。那么凯蒂，为了那些可能完全不知道《恋爱岛》是什么的英国听众和海外听众，你能简单介绍一下它涉及的内容吗？当然。嗯，据我所知，它已经播出了六季。本质上，《恋爱岛》就是把一群长相非常出众的人带到马略卡岛的一个岛上，
and they're completely cut off from the outside world. So they have a phone, but they can only talk to the other islanders on the phone. They have no idea what people are saying on Twitter, which is kind of part of the fun, is looking at all the memes that come out of the show. And essentially the aim of the show is to win. So you get 50 grand at the end of it
他们与外界完全隔绝。他们有手机，但只能用手机和其他岛民交流。他们完全不知道推特上的人在说什么，而看节目产生的各种梗图也是乐趣的一部分。节目的目标本质上就是获胜。最后你会得到5万英镑，
and you can decide whether you are going to split that money with your partner or you're going to keep it. So the aim of the game is to show, are you really in it for love or are you doing it? Are you selfish, egocentric grasper? Yeah, to become an influencer and and sell yeah and like sell expensive uh toothpaste but how does the so the contest so what are they doing are they kissing what are they because my son says some of his some of the girls at school
你可以决定是和你的伴侣平分这笔钱，还是独吞。所以游戏的目的是展示：你是真的为了爱情而来，还是为了其他目的？你是一个自私、以自我为中心的贪婪者吗？是的，为了成为网红，然后去卖昂贵的牙膏。但参赛者们在做什么？他们在接吻吗？因为我儿子说他学校里的一些女孩，
some of the 10 year old girls have seen it but they call it the love kiss show so so presumably there must be some love kiss as well as islanding going on so yeah good question um so every single week there's a thing called the recoupling um so it'll either be the boys that choose the girl that they want to couple up with or the girls choose um and the moral of the show is if you're single you get dumped from the island right okay so there's so there's real jeopardy so basically people have to pair up so that's that's you have to you have to try and kiss anyone who okay okay just one quick question can i just intervene the coupling up as you call it yeah i mean they're I mean, to ask a very boring, well, not a boring, a very exciting logistical question.
一些10岁的女孩看过这个节目，但她们把它叫作“恋爱接吻秀”。所以，想必除了在岛上生活，肯定还有一些恋爱接吻的环节。是的，好问题。每周都有一个叫“重新配对”（recoupling）的环节。要么是男生选择他们想配对的女生，要么是女生选择。节目的规则是，如果你单身，就会被踢出岛。好吧，所以真的有风险。基本上人们必须配对，所以你必须尝试去亲吻任何人。好吧，好吧，我能插一句吗？你们所说的“配对”，我是说，问一个非常无聊，或者说非常令人兴奋的后勤问题。
They're not kind of physically coupling on TV in front of the cameras. Are they or are they? They did in, okay. So they did in recent series when it was less famous. But I think now the stakes are higher. So that also adds another layer of complexity. It's like, are people really in it for love anymore okay okay so we are going to send five hunks and five babes um not to Mallorca but to Dominic Sandbrook's Fantasy Island Pleasure Island Tom sorry Dominic Sandbrook's Pleasure Island for those people who don't know
他们不是在电视上当着摄像机的面进行身体上的结合吧？是吗？还是不是？在最近的几季里，当它还没那么出名的时候，他们确实有过。但我认为现在赌注更高了。所以这也增加了一层复杂性。就像，人们真的是为了爱情吗？好吧，好吧，所以我们要派出五位帅哥和五位美女，不是去马略卡岛，而是去多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook）的“幻想岛”——“享乐岛”。汤姆，抱歉，多米尼克·桑德布鲁克的“享乐岛”，对于那些不知道的人来说，
that was the name that the BBC wanted to give a TV documentary that I made. Just to be clear as well about one other thing. I'm so excited about this episode that I've lost my voice. That adds another level of complexity to the discussion. So we are going to send five historical hunks and five historical babes to Dominic Zanbrook's Fantasy Island. Pleasure Island. Pleasure Island. and they will then have to to couple up but katie we asked you to to nominate uh 10 archetypes and you sourced all your friends didn't you and so this is a kind of a group your group conclusion as to as to the um the 10 archetypes of of the contestants on love island so could you
那是BBC想为我制作的一部电视纪录片起的名字。另外还要澄清一件事。我对这一集太兴奋了，以至于嗓子都哑了。这给讨论增加了一层复杂性。所以我们要把五位历史上的帅哥和五位历史上的美女送到多米尼克·桑德布鲁克的“幻想岛”——“享乐岛”。他们必须配对。但凯蒂，我们让你提名10种原型，你咨询了你所有的朋友，对吧？所以这是一个你们集体得出的关于《恋爱岛》参赛者10种原型的结论。你能
just give them to us? Yeah, of course. And I'm really sorry in advance if I've missed any, but I did ask my friends just in case. Okay. So I've put them into two groups. So men and women, but they could apply to either gender, but I think Dom and Tom,
把它们告诉我们吗？当然可以。如果我漏掉了什么，我提前道歉，但我确实问过我的朋友们以防万一。好的，我把它们分成了两组：男性和女性。虽然它们可能适用于任何性别，但我认为多姆和汤姆，
you've just put them according to the standards i gave you so okay so men so for the first one i said player very good looking keeps changing his mind about who he wants to be with the second one is the kind of sweet shit one who doesn't get anywhere and usually has quite a wholesome job so the classic archetype this is dr alex in season four he was a doctor of course dr alex yeah um number three is the traitor he's very similar to the player but pretends he's not um and pretends he's more into his partner than he is and then at castle and more which usually happens in the fourth week they get sent to another house where they have the opportunity to meet loads of more people. And they potentially, they pretty much always come back with a new girl after they come back to the main villa.
你们只是按照我给的标准把它们放进去了。好的，男性：第一个我说是“玩家”（Player），长相非常帅气，总是改变主意想和谁在一起。第二个是那种“甜心笨蛋”（Sweet shit），哪里都混不开，通常有一份相当正经的工作。经典的例子是第四季的亚历克斯医生（Dr. Alex），他当然是个医生。是的，亚历克斯医生。第三个是“叛徒”（Traitor），他和玩家很像，但假装不是，而且假装比实际更喜欢他的伴侣。然后到了第四周左右，他们通常会被送到另一个房子，在那里有机会见到更多的人。他们几乎总是会在回到主别墅后带回一个新女孩。
The number four is the producer's favourite. So usually pairs up with someone on the first day, stays with them and wins the competition. Always very likeable and unproblematic. And then, yeah yeah my dad loved this one the funny one a top lad loves the lads leader of the lads so that's the the five men then for the women I've done number one the bombshell who turns up and causes havoc um so she steals someone else's man and doesn't care. The stupid but lovable one. The justifiably angry jilted one.
第四个是“制片人的宠儿”（Producer's favourite）。通常第一天就和某人配对，一直和他们在一起并赢得比赛。总是非常讨人喜欢，没有争议。然后，是的，我爸爸喜欢这个，那个“搞笑的人”（Funny one），一个顶级小伙，热爱兄弟情，是兄弟们的领袖。这就是五个男性原型。然后是女性，我列了第一个：“炸弹”（Bombshell），她出现并引起混乱，抢走别人的男人，而且毫不在乎。第二个是“愚蠢但可爱的人”（Stupid but lovable one）。第三个是“有正当理由愤怒的被抛弃者”（Justifiably angry jilted one）。
He will call her extra chat and tell him off in front of everyone. Another producer's favourite. He will pair up with the other producer's favourite, stay with them and win the competition. And then the gossip who lives for the drama and will ruminate on whether people actually like each other or are they in it for the fame okay those are those are the archetypes that i gave i hope they're faithful to the show thank you very much okay so uh dominic we've divided them
她会当众指责他，让他难堪。另一个是“制片人的宠儿”。她会和另一个制片人的宠儿配对，一直在一起并赢得比赛。最后是“八卦者”（Gossip），她为戏剧性而活，会反复琢磨人们是否真的喜欢对方，还是为了名气。好的，这就是我给出的原型，希望它们忠实于节目。非常感谢。好的，多米尼克，我们把它们
up haven't we we have indeed so we've each got five that we're putting into the house. So, um, should I go first? Go for it. So, so I, I've chosen, uh, the, the first, uh, male, um,
分好了，对吧？确实如此。所以我们每个人都有五个要放进房子里的人。那么，我先来？请便。所以我选择了第一个男性
archetype, the player who's very good looking, keeps changing his mind about who he wants to be with. And the historical hottie that I am sending in is George Gordon, Lord Byron, uh, brilliant poet, uh,
原型，“玩家”，长相非常帅气，总是改变主意想和谁在一起。我派出的历史帅哥是乔治·戈登，拜伦勋爵（George Gordon, Lord Byron），杰出的诗人，
notorious lover. Um, and to say that he, I i mean he was incredibly good looking he had the one the one thing he was very self-conscious about he had a club foot and so he didn't he didn't actually like to kind of strip off that's a problem on the love island that is that that is an issue however uh he was a superb swimmer he loved swimming because obviously then he could he was as mobile as he was tended to be immobile when walking so um presumably there's a there's a swimming pool in this villa so he would he'd be very very proficient in the swimming
臭名昭著的情圣。要说他，我的意思是，他长得极其帅气。他唯一感到自卑的是他有一只内翻足，所以他其实不喜欢脱衣服。这在《恋爱岛》上是个问题，确实是个问题。然而，他是一位出色的游泳运动员，他热爱游泳，因为显然这样他就能像他走路时那样灵活，而他走路时往往是不灵活的。所以，想必别墅里有一个游泳池，他会在游泳池里表现得非常出色。
pool yeah but what's he gonna wear like a wetsuit i mean he's got to strip off uh well he'd have to wear i mean i think they're all wearing tight speedos, aren't they? Katie, is that right? They all wear tight speedos. Byron swam the Hellespont, so I think he'd have no problem just spending the whole time in the swimming pool. Yeah, there is also a swimming pool to show off. Great, great. So Byron would be good there. He's the kind of guy who cheated on his wife with his half-sister. That's the measure of the man.
是的，但他会穿什么？潜水服吗？我是说他得脱掉衣服。嗯，他得穿，我想他们都穿紧身泳裤，对吧？凯蒂，是这样吗？他们都穿紧身泳裤。拜伦游过赫勒斯滂海峡，所以我想他整天泡在游泳池里一点问题都没有。是的，还有一个游泳池可以炫耀。太棒了。所以拜伦在那里会表现得很好。他就是那种和同父异母的妹妹出轨的人。这就是那个人的衡量标准。
That's very David Lloyd George. I mean, he just had a sequence of explosively notorious affairs, perhaps the most notorious one, Lady Caroline Lamb, wife of future Prime Minister Lord Melbourne, who was so obsessed with him that she sent him clippings of her pubic hair
这非常像大卫·劳合·乔治（David Lloyd George）。我的意思是，他有一连串爆炸性的臭名昭著的恋情，也许最臭名昭著的是卡罗琳·兰姆夫人（Lady Caroline Lamb），未来首相墨尔本勋爵的妻子。她对他如此痴迷，以至于在信中寄给他
in a letter. When he dumped her, she faked a suicide at the Duke of Wellington's ball. She got all her servants to dress up in white wispy dresses and to dance around a bonfire. And then she chucked all his letters in. And Byron, so Byron would be great. I mean, I guess the kind of the dialogue, what they talk, how they communicate with each other is very important on Love Island. So Byron was great. Byron's response to this. Lady Caroline Lamb crept into Byron's house and found one of his one of his books and wrote in the fly life.
她的阴毛剪报。当他甩了她时，她在威灵顿公爵的舞会上假装自杀。她让所有的仆人都穿上白色的薄纱裙，围着篝火跳舞。然后她把他的信全都扔了进去。拜伦，所以拜伦会很棒。我的意思是，我猜对话，他们如何交流，在《恋爱岛》上非常重要。所以拜伦很棒。拜伦对此的回应。卡罗琳·兰姆夫人潜入拜伦的房子，找到他的一本书，在扉页上写道：“生命。
Remember me. And Byron replied, remember thee, remember thee till lethe quench life's burning stream. Remorse and shame shall cling to thee and haunt thee like a feverish dream. Remember thee, I doubt it not. Thy husband too shall think of thee. By neither shalt thou be forgot. Thou false to him, thou fiend to me. So that's the kind of banter that Byron would be bringing. But Tom, in very Byronic form, you're talking too much about byron we've got loads more to go through so excellent choice uh and also a
记住我。”拜伦回复道：“记住你，记住你，直到勒特河（Lethe）熄灭生命燃烧的溪流。悔恨和羞耻将缠绕着你，像一场狂热的梦一样困扰着你。记住你，我毫不怀疑。你的丈夫也会想起你。你们俩都不会忘记你。你对他不忠，你对我而言是恶魔。”这就是拜伦会带来的那种调侃。但汤姆，以非常拜伦式的形式，你谈论拜伦太多了，我们还有很多要讲，所以选择很棒。而且还有一个
fantastic description of him from his personal physician lord polidori who just they were going on holiday together uh and polidori said of byron that as soon as he reached his room he fell like a thunderbolt upon the chambermaid they They do write each other messages in tea towels when they ask people to be their girlfriend. So they'll write it on the lawn. On the tea towel. And say, I love you. So maybe he can write his poem in the tea towel.
来自他的私人医生波利多里勋爵（Lord Polidori）对他的精彩描述，他们一起去度假，波利多里说拜伦一回到房间，就像雷霆一样扑向了女仆。他们确实会在要求别人做女朋友时在茶巾上写信息。所以他们会写在草坪上。在茶巾上。说，我爱你。所以也许他可以在茶巾上写他的诗。
All right, who's your next one, Tom? Well, I think it's your turn. You should give us one. All right. So I was told to choose the sweet one who doesn't get anywhere, usually does a wholesome job. And I've chosen the former US president, Jimmy Carter. Good choice.
好了，汤姆，下一个是谁？嗯，我想轮到你了。你应该给我们一个。好的。所以我被告知要选择那个“甜心笨蛋”，哪里都混不开，通常有一份正经工作。我选择了美国前总统吉米·卡特（Jimmy Carter）。好选择。
So Jimmy Carter, Katie, one-term president, former peanut farmer from Georgia. I think he's going to suffer, frankly, on a couple of things. One is he's a teetotaler. And I don't know if they're allowed alcohol on Love Island, but I think it doesn't speak of a sort of party animal spirit that he refused to have alcohol served in the White House. But he had peanuts, didn't he?
所以吉米·卡特，凯蒂，一届总统，来自佐治亚州的前花生农。坦率地说，我认为他在几件事上会很痛苦。一个是他是禁酒主义者。我不知道《恋爱岛》上是否允许喝酒，但我认为这并不符合那种派对动物的精神，他拒绝在白宫供应酒精。但他有花生，不是吗？
He was a peanut farmer. Well, he was a peanut farmer. I don't know whether peanuts will avail him much on Love Island. Might be popular. So he's married to Rosalind, Jimmy Carter, and he's very uxorious. There's absolutely no suggestion of hanky-panky. They've got a daughter called Amy.
他是个花生农。嗯，他是个花生农。我不知道花生在《恋爱岛》上对他有什么帮助。可能很受欢迎。所以他娶了罗莎琳（Rosalind），吉米·卡特，他非常宠爱妻子。完全没有乱搞的迹象。他们有一个女儿叫艾米（Amy）。
But the sort of slightly complicating factor for Jimmy is that he's an evangelical Christian. He's born again. He's the first evangelical Christian president in modern American history. But when he was running for the presidency in 1976, he gave an interview to Playboy in which he, in very sort of evangelical style, he sort of lambasted himself about being full of sin.
但对吉米来说，稍微复杂一点的因素是他是一位福音派基督徒。他是重生派。他是现代美国历史上第一位福音派基督徒总统。但在1976年竞选总统时，他接受了《花花公子》的采访，在采访中，他以一种非常福音派的风格，对自己充满了罪恶感进行了抨击。
And he said, I don't think of myself as better than other people i'm actually a seasoned and practiced adulterer uh because i've looked um because although i haven't actually done it in reality i've looked on women with lust i've i often find myself looking on other women with lust and i know that this is terrible behavior um so i think for somebody like jimmy carter who's quite buttoned up never drank spent a lot of time with peanuts going to camp david and trying to do talks and um trying to stop people use too much electricity which is basically his thing or too much petrol i think the shock of love island it would be very very interesting how how would how he'd look quite good in his speedos, wouldn't he?
他说：“我不认为自己比别人好，我实际上是一个经验丰富的通奸者，因为我曾看过……”因为虽然我在现实中没有做过，但我曾带着欲望注视女性。我经常发现自己带着欲望注视其他女性，我知道这是可怕的行为。所以我想对于像吉米·卡特这样的人，他非常保守，从不喝酒，花很多时间种花生，去戴维营试图做演讲，试图阻止人们使用过多的电力，这基本上是他的事，或者过多的汽油。我想《恋爱岛》的冲击对他来说会非常非常有趣。他穿紧身泳裤看起来会很不错，不是吗？
Because he went for runs. Well, he went for a run and collapsed, Tom. Yes. So he famously went for a run and collapsed. He also went boating and was attacked by a killer rabbit, a swamp rabbit. So he's an accident prone. He's kind of accident prone. I'm just anxious about the committing lust in his heart
因为他去跑步。嗯，他去跑步然后晕倒了，汤姆。是的。所以他因为跑步晕倒而闻名。他还去划船，被一只杀手兔，一只沼泽兔袭击了。所以他是个容易出事故的人。他有点容易出事故。我只是担心他在心里犯下的欲望，
because i think that sets a bad precedent and if he's coming out with that first of all if he's coming out with that stuff on the island what are the girls gonna think and secondly um you know is it all gonna be too much for him is he gonna suddenly abandon his faith and his kind of long cherished principles and just go wild? Or will he just sit in the corner and cry? It's very hard to say. Yeah. Well,
因为我认为这开了一个坏先例。如果他一开始就在岛上说这些话，女孩们会怎么想？其次，你知道，这一切对他来说会不会太多了？他会不会突然放弃他的信仰和他长期珍视的原则，然后变得狂野？还是他只会坐在角落里哭？很难说。是的。嗯，
I mean, that's, that's all the excitement, isn't it? It is. They have to do, they have to do video confessions. Will he be great at that?
我的意思是，这就是所有的兴奋点，不是吗？是的。他们必须做视频忏悔。他会擅长这个吗？
Yeah. It's like Big Brother. I think he'd probably have an existential crisis in one of the, in one of the films. But how would, how would, how would that play with the, with the fans, Katie? what do you mean like with the yeah jimmy i think they'd love him you think they'd love him i think so i think the memes would start pretty much straight away yeah
是的。就像《老大哥》（Big Brother）。我想他可能会在其中一个拍摄点经历存在主义危机。但凯蒂，这对粉丝们来说会怎么样？你是什么意思，比如和……是的，吉米，我想他们会喜欢他的。你认为他们会喜欢他？我想是的，我想梗图会立刻出现。是的，
but they'd be kind of in in good nature see there's part of me that thinks that actually he he could get quite far in the competition well we'll find out we don't know yeah usually they they keep the the kind of the one he's not very good at getting the women in for quite a long time all right well he's got to hope then because he's a fan favorite so so that's lord byron and jimmy carter um let's move on to the women so um i've got the stupid but lovable one um and i this was actually quite difficult because there aren't many stupid but lovable people who kind of make a name for themselves in history. They're either very clever or they're not very lovable.
但它们会是善意的。你看，我有一部分觉得他实际上可以在比赛中走得很远。好吧，我们会发现的，我们不知道。是的，通常他们会让那种不太擅长吸引女性的人留很长时间。好吧，那他得有希望了，因为他是粉丝的最爱。所以这就是拜伦勋爵和吉米·卡特。让我们继续谈谈女性。所以，我有“愚蠢但可爱的人”，这其实很难，因为历史上没有多少愚蠢但可爱的人能成名。他们要么非常聪明，要么不太可爱。
But the person that I have nominated is Frances Stewart, who lived between 1647 and 1702. She was born to royalist courtiers during the Civil War, the English Civil War. So they moved to Paris. She was born two years before courtiers during the civil war the english civil war so they moved to paris um and she was born two years before the execution of charles i so she grew up outside england um but when charles ii went back to england with the restoration she went and first of all she she was a kind of lady in waiting to charles ii's mother and then to his wife catherine of Braganza. And she was stunningly beautiful.
但我提名的人是弗朗西丝·斯图尔特（Frances Stewart），她生活在1647年到1702年之间。她出生在内战期间的保皇派廷臣家庭，英国内战。所以他们搬到了巴黎。她出生在查理一世被处决前两年，所以她在英国之外长大。但当查理二世回到英国复辟时，她去了，首先她是查理二世母亲的侍女，然后是他的妻子凯瑟琳·德·布拉干萨（Catherine of Braganza）的侍女。她美得惊人。
So she was known as La Belle Stuart. Everyone at Charles II's court was obsessed with her. Samuel Pepys went on and on about how gorgeous she was. Duke of Buckingham fell head over heels in love with her. But the person, the biggest person who fell in love with her was Charles II himself, who was desperate to make her his mistress. And Frances Stewart was so dumb that she turned him down. And she was described by a French courtier that it would be difficult to imagine
所以她被称为“美丽的斯图尔特”（La Belle Stuart）。查理二世宫廷里的每个人都对她着迷。塞缪尔·佩皮斯（Samuel Pepys）不停地谈论她有多漂亮。白金汉公爵（Duke of Buckingham）疯狂地爱上了她。但那个爱上她的人中最大的人物是查理二世本人，他拼命想让她成为他的情妇。而弗朗西丝·斯图尔特太笨了，她拒绝了他。一位法国廷臣形容她，很难想象
less brain combined with more beauty. Wow. So, and she was so beautiful that she became the model for the first um portrait of britannia that appeared on kind of medals and coins issued in in in 1667 which was the same year that she ended up finally pairing up with someone who was actually not a bad catch the duke of richmond so she became the duchess of richmond um and and then lived a very happy life so um she she may have been dumb but but she was beautiful and happy. So I think that she'd be, I think she'd be very popular.
更少的头脑结合更多的美貌。哇。所以，她太美了，以至于她成为了1667年发行的奖章和硬币上出现的第一个不列颠尼亚（Britannia）肖像的模特。同一年，她最终与一个其实还不错的人——里士满公爵（Duke of Richmond）配对，所以她成为了里士满公爵夫人，然后过上了非常幸福的生活。所以，她可能很笨，但她很漂亮也很幸福。所以我认为她会非常受欢迎。
Oh, excellent choice. She's going to go far. Yeah, I think so. All right. So I'll choose a woman. One of your categories, Katie, was the gossip. In it for the drama and ruminates on whether women, people actually like each other in it for the money.
噢，绝佳的选择。她会走得很远。是的，我想是的。好的，那我也选一个女性。凯蒂，你的类别之一是“八卦者”。为戏剧性而活，反复琢磨人们是否真的喜欢对方，还是为了钱。
So I've chosen another 1970s character. I've chosen Marcia Williams, Lady Falkinder. So she was Harold Wilson's political secretary, but she was an immensely controversial figure in British life in the 70s. So she's from quite a humble background. She's the daughter, I think, of a Northamptonshire builder. And she's not an immensely good-looking northamptonshire builder and um she's she's not an immensely good looking woman i think it's fair to say so uh but she's very charismatic and very
所以我选择了另一个1970年代的人物。我选择了玛西娅·威廉姆斯（Marcia Williams），福尔金德夫人（Lady Falkinder）。她是哈罗德·威尔逊（Harold Wilson）的政治秘书，但在70年代的英国生活中，她是一个极具争议的人物。她出身相当卑微。我想她是北安普敦郡一位建筑商的女儿。她不是一个非常漂亮的女人，我想说这是公平的，但她非常有魅力，而且非常
clever and she's always plotting and scheming in wilson's sort of back office um she was married earlier and then divorced she has two children secretly with the political editor of the daily mail um she might odd thing for a for a labor insider to do and and that but later on there's a lot of controversy about whether or not she was accepting secret donations from shady businessmen to pay for her children's school fees which you might say is again slightly interesting from um uh the a labor special advisor. But basically, there was always this suspicion that hung around her
聪明，她总是在威尔逊的办公室里策划和阴谋。她早年结过婚，后来离婚了。她和《每日邮报》的政治编辑秘密生了两个孩子，这对于一个工党内部人士来说可能是一件奇怪的事情。后来，关于她是否接受了来自阴暗商人的秘密捐款来支付她孩子的学费，有很多争议，你可能会说这对于工党特别顾问来说再次有点意思。但基本上，一直有这种怀疑笼罩着她，
about whether she was, pouring poison the whole time into Harold Wilson's ear and poisoning him against his ministers. And B, whether the two of them were secretly having an affair.
关于她是否一直在哈罗德·威尔逊耳边吹风，毒害他对他部长的看法。以及，他们两人是否在秘密偷情。
And the story, one of his aides said that, claimed that in one of their many blazing rows that they would have in Downing Street, rows that would basically put sort of Boris and Carrie's, Carrie on to shame. Sometimes she would raise her handbag and she'd tap her handbag and she'd point to it meaningfully and she'd say, I have things in here that will destroy you. One call to the Daily Mail and you'll be finished. That's what I do with Tom, actually, a lot with your dad. Yeah, it is. It is.
故事是这样的，他的一位助手声称，在唐宁街发生的许多激烈争吵中，那些争吵基本上让鲍里斯和凯莉（Boris and Carrie）的争吵相形见绌。有时她会举起手提包，拍拍手提包，意味深长地指着它说：“我这里面有能毁了你的东西。给《每日邮报》打一个电话，你就完了。”其实我和汤姆在一起时经常这样做，和你爸爸。是的，确实。
Is that Love Island behaviour, Katie? The other thing is apparently at one point, I'm not sure if it's in Downing Street or just before they get into Downing Street, they have a massive row. So that's Marcia Williams, Harold and Mary, his wife. And Marcia rants at Mary. And she says, I have only one thing to say to you.
这是《恋爱岛》的行为吗，凯蒂？另一件事是，显然有一次，我不确定是在唐宁街还是在进入唐宁街之前，他们发生了一场巨大的争吵。那是玛西娅·威廉姆斯、哈罗德和他的妻子玛丽。玛西娅对玛丽咆哮。她说：“我只有一句话要对你说。”
I went to bed with your husband five times in 1955. And it was not satisfactory. So, and then, of course, when Harold Wilson resigns, there are claims that basically she wrote his resignation honours list for him on lavender notepaper, the lavender list, as it was called, basically giving peerages to all her cronies in return for help with the school fees. So that's Marcia Williams.
“我在1955年和你丈夫睡过五次。而且并不令人满意。”所以，当然，当哈罗德·威尔逊辞职时，有说法称基本上是她在薰衣草色的信纸上为他写了辞职荣誉名单，“薰衣草名单”，正如它所称的那样，基本上是给她的所有亲信授予爵位，以换取学费方面的帮助。所以这就是玛西娅·威廉姆斯。
I think she'd be a combustible character on Love Island. I think the issue of the satisfactoriness or otherwise of the couplings would obviously, you know, play a part. And I don't know. I mean, I don't see her as a fan favourite, but I think certainly the newspapers would enjoy her presence. Yeah, I don't know. I kind of think everyone would say whoever found her deserves a pay rise
我认为她在《恋爱岛》上会是一个易燃的角色。关于配对是否令人满意的问题显然会发挥作用。我不知道。我的意思是，我不认为她是粉丝的最爱，但我认为报纸肯定会喜欢她的存在。是的，我不知道。我有点认为每个人都会说，谁发现了她，谁就应该加薪，
because she's such a good TV. Yeah. Yeah. Good. I get a pay rise because she's such good tv yeah yeah good i get pay rise brilliant okay so okay so um i've got another woman next um and this is the bombshell who turns up and causes havoc steals someone else's man and doesn't care so so katie this is um this is a person who was born eliza Gilbert. So same name as your sister. But she's much flightier than our Eliza. So she was of Irish stock, but spent her early childhood in India, then came back, went to school in Scotland, in the northeast of England. She used to run naked through the streets, which caused some eyebrows to be raised. And this was at the beginning of the 19th century. So she's born in 1821 so this is the victorian period so you can imagine that running naked
因为她太有电视效果了。是的，是的。好。我加薪是因为她太有电视效果了，是的，是的，好。我加薪，太棒了。好的，所以……好的，我下一个还有一位女性。这是那个“炸弹”，她出现并引起混乱，抢走别人的男人，而且毫不在乎。所以，凯蒂，这是一个出生时叫伊丽莎·吉尔伯特（Eliza Gilbert）的人。和你妹妹名字一样。但她比我们的伊丽莎轻浮得多。她是爱尔兰血统，但童年早期在印度度过，然后回来，在苏格兰、英格兰东北部上学。她过去常常赤身裸体在街上跑，这引起了一些人的侧目。这是在19世纪初。所以她出生于1821年，这是维多利亚时代，所以你可以想象赤身裸体
through the streets in victorian scotland was not a common not a common thing 16 age 16 she elopes with a soldier so very kind of pride and prejudice uh it goes back to india um She has a massive bust up with her husband, leaves him in Calcutta, comes back to London and she has become a dancer. And not only has she become a dancer, but she pretends to be a Spanish dancer. And she has taken on the name of Lola Montes. So she performs as a dancer. She's probably not just a dancer and she gets recognised as having been Eliza Gilbert and so she flees to the continent where she she has a spectacular career as a courtesan so in Paris she has an affair with uh Alexandre Dumas who writes the Three Musketeers um very very shrewdly and I think this is very Love Island behavior she has an affair with a French guy who not only owns a
在维多利亚时代的苏格兰街头奔跑并不是一件常见的事情。16岁时，她与一名士兵私奔，非常像《傲慢与偏见》。回到印度，她和丈夫大吵一架，在加尔各答离开了他，回到伦敦，她成了一名舞者。而且她不仅成了一名舞者，还假装自己是西班牙舞者。她取名罗拉·蒙特兹（Lola Montes）。所以她以舞者身份表演。她可能不仅仅是舞者，她被认出是伊丽莎·吉尔伯特，于是她逃往欧洲大陆，在那里她作为交际花有着辉煌的职业生涯。在巴黎，她与亚历山大·仲马（Alexandre Dumas）有染，他写了《三个火枪手》。非常非常精明，我认为这是非常《恋爱岛》的行为，她与一个法国人有染，他不仅拥有
newspaper but is the dance correspondent. So can obviously write amazing reviews of Lola Montes, bigging her up. Is she in it for the money? She's in it for the money because she just burns through men like nobody's business. And having kind of got off with this newspaper critic, she then gets her biggest catch, who is Ludwig I of Bavaria, who basically allows her to run the country until there's a revolution in 1848 and Lele Montes has to kind of go running off. So having been kicked out from Bavaria, she goes back to London, where she marries again. This is a bigamist relationship, so, you know, illegal. So she flees to America, where she has further marriages, further affairs, people that she's had an affair with.
一家报纸，还是舞蹈评论员。所以显然可以写出关于罗拉·蒙特兹的精彩评论，把她捧红。她是为钱吗？她是为钱，因为她像没人管一样挥霍男人。在搞定了这个报纸评论员之后，她又钓到了她最大的猎物，巴伐利亚的路德维希一世（Ludwig I of Bavaria），他基本上允许她管理国家，直到1848年发生革命，罗拉·蒙特兹不得不逃跑。所以被赶出巴伐利亚后，她回到伦敦，在那里再次结婚。这是一段重婚关系，所以，你知道，是非法的。所以她逃往美国，在那里她有更多的婚姻，更多的恋情，她有过恋情的人。
They all end up getting murdered or disappearing. She goes to Australia where she she has a notorious art, the spider dance, which kind of is a kind of can can. She horse whips people who annoy her. And she's just it's just generally it's kind of chaos, drama. She'd be an amazing, amazing contestant. She's she's had a huge impact on literature. So she's probably the model for Irene Adler in the Sherlock Holmes story, A Scandal in Bohemia. And in the Flashman series, Flashman has an affair with her in Royal Flash.
他们最终都遭到谋杀或失踪。她去了澳大利亚，在那里她有一个臭名昭著的艺术表演，“蜘蛛舞”，这是一种康康舞。她用马鞭抽打惹恼她的人。她基本上就是混乱、戏剧性。她会是一个了不起的、了不起的参赛者。她对文学产生了巨大的影响。所以她可能是福尔摩斯故事《波希米亚丑闻》中艾琳·艾德勒（Irene Adler）的原型。在《闪电侠》（Flashman）系列中，闪电侠在《皇家闪电侠》中与她有染。
So she she would be a combustible highly entertaining highly glamorous um contender she could do her spider dance i think would be a great fan favorite um and she would just i mean she i think she'd find it very hard to stay coupled with one person unless she could be absolutely certain that person was going to win in which case she'd probably stick with him. Such a good choice. She really reminds me of my favourite all-time Love Islander, Moira. Who's that? Which will mean nothing to you. But she's the best person I've ever seen on TV.
所以她会是一个易燃、极具娱乐性、极具魅力的竞争者。她可以跳她的蜘蛛舞，我认为她会成为粉丝的最爱。她会……我的意思是，我认为她很难和一个人保持配对，除非她能绝对确定那个人会赢，在这种情况下，她可能会坚持和他在一起。真是个好选择。她真的让我想起了我最喜欢的《恋爱岛》选手，莫伊拉（Moira）。那是谁？这对你来说毫无意义。但她是我在电视上见过的最好的人。
And she was also Irish. She surely wasn't the first person you'd ever seen on TV. You must have seen people on TV before. But she's the best person I've ever seen on TV. The best person? I thought you said the first person. Oh, not the first. I had a terrible insight then into the Holland household.
而且她也是爱尔兰人。她肯定不是你见过的第一个电视上的人。你以前肯定见过电视上的人。但她是我在电视上见过的最好的人。最好的人？我还以为你说的是第一个人。噢，不是第一个。我刚才对霍兰德家有了可怕的洞察。
You're banned from watching television until Love Island. Until Love Island comes on. Victorian dad gets it wrong. But there's actually a dance competition. Oh, well. I've got a dancer up my sleeve, Katie, but I'll hold her back for the time being
在《恋爱岛》之前，你被禁止看电视。直到《恋爱岛》播出。维多利亚时代的爸爸搞错了。但其实有一个舞蹈比赛。噢，好吧。我袖子里有一个舞者，凯蒂，但我暂时先留着她，
because I think she's a bit similar to Lola Montez, but also I want her to have the maximum possible impact, so I'll bring her in near the end. So just one more before the break. So you wanted a traitor, didn't you? You wanted a male traitor, very similar to the player, but with the difference that he pretends to be more into his partner than he is,
因为我觉得她和罗拉·蒙特兹有点像，而且我也想让她产生最大的影响，所以我会在快结束时让她出场。所以在休息前再来一个。所以你想要一个叛徒，对吧？你想要一个男性叛徒，和玩家很像，但区别在于他假装比实际更喜欢他的伴侣，
and then randomly pairs up with somebody else. So when I saw the word traitor, I thought I'm just going to go in quite big with this. I'm going to go with the traitor. So I've gone with Judas. That's a massive choice, a massive choice. So Judas enters the island. So what we know of Judas,
然后随机和别人配对。所以当我看到“叛徒”这个词时，我想我打算玩个大的。我要选那个叛徒。所以我选了犹大（Judas）。这是一个巨大的选择，巨大的选择。所以犹大进入了岛上。所以我们所知道的犹大，
I think there is some doubt about whether Judas is there for love or whether he's there for the money, or more specifically for the 30 pieces of silver um so that that's I mean Judas has got form I think it's fair to say that although some of the other love islanders may not have heard of each other they'll all have by and large have heard of Judas so he comes in with baggage yeah and he's already guilty of one absolutely colossal betrayal as he comes into the island. But the interesting thing about Judas and what I think makes him a wild card in this competition,
我想关于犹大是为了爱还是为了钱，或者更具体地说是为了那30块银币，存在一些疑问。所以这就是……我的意思是犹大有前科，我认为公平地说，虽然其他《恋爱岛》选手可能没听说过彼此，但他们大体上都听说过犹大。所以他带着包袱进来。是的，而且他在进入岛上时已经犯下了一次绝对巨大的背叛。但关于犹大的有趣之处，以及我认为让他成为这场比赛中一张王牌的原因，
I mean, he's got a lot of meme potential because he ended up hanging himself from a tree, didn't he, Tom? Yeah, he did. So fame didn't make him happy. Fame and wealth didn't make him happy. And also with the 30 pieces of silver. But also the truth of the matter is, when it comes to sort of affairs of the heart,
我的意思是，他有很多梗图潜力，因为他最终在树上上吊自杀了，不是吗，汤姆？是的，他确实。所以名声并没有让他快乐。名声和财富并没有让他快乐。而且还有那30块银币。但事实是，当谈到心灵事务时，
Judas is something of an enigma. We don't know anything about his romantic history, do we? I mean, oddly, the Bible is silent on Judas' love life. So we just don't know how he's going to interact with the others. How's he going to get on with Lola Montez? Will he be pals with Lord Byron? Or I mean, Jimmy Carter obviously is going to have massive issues with Judas.
犹大是一个谜。我们对他的浪漫史一无所知，对吧？我的意思是，奇怪的是，圣经对犹大的爱情生活只字未提。所以我们根本不知道他将如何与其他人互动。他会和罗拉·蒙特兹相处得怎么样？他会和拜伦勋爵成为伙伴吗？或者我的意思是，吉米·卡特显然会和犹大有巨大的冲突。
Yeah. From the get go. Yeah. Cause Jimmy, you know, will be horrified to see Judas pitch up. I mean, there is of course the,
是的。从一开始。是的。因为吉米，你知道，看到犹大出现会感到震惊。我的意思是，当然有，
the plot twist that you get in Jesus Christ superstar, where actually he's, he's betraying Jesus simply to try and get jesus to you know reveal himself as the messiah so that suggests a kind of a talent for tricksy behavior for kind of psychological play that doesn't always come off so that might be interesting he might think the sort of judas marcia williams i could see them yeah if not coupling up then certainly they could play an interesting part stirring up the others against one another yeah and so on okay so anyway yeah um i'd be very i'm i'm particularly keen katie to see how judas gets on in this competition so do you think his motors might be more pure or maybe well this is the enigma i mean this is this is the fascination of it, isn't it? And that will be for the audience to decide.
在《万世巨星》（Jesus Christ Superstar）中的情节转折，实际上他背叛耶稣只是为了试图让耶稣揭示自己是弥赛亚。这表明了一种耍花招的行为天赋，一种心理博弈，并不总是奏效。所以这可能很有趣。他可能会认为那种犹大、玛西娅·威廉姆斯的组合……我能看到他们，是的，如果不是配对，他们肯定可以在煽动其他人对抗彼此等方面发挥有趣的作用。所以，无论如何，是的，我特别渴望看到犹大在这场比赛中表现如何。所以你认为他的动机可能更纯粹，或者也许……嗯，这就是谜团，我的意思是，这就是它的魅力所在，不是吗？这将由观众来决定。
I mean, the man who's already sold himself for 30 pieces of silver, 50 grand is a hell of a lot of money to Judas. Yeah, yeah. What will he do for 50 grand? I think on that cliffhanger, we should take a break. And when we come back, we'll look at the other five contenders.
我的意思是，那个已经为了30块银币出卖自己的人，5万英镑对犹大来说是一大笔钱。是的，是的。他会为了5万英镑做什么？我想在那个悬念上，我们应该休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将看看另外五位竞争者。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestis of the entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com welcome back to love island the tension is mounting the excitement is a fever pitch we're joined by top love island uh connoisseur enthusiast meme generator and all-round expert Katie Holland um who is of course the daughter of top uh TV historian
我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《历史的余味：娱乐篇》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是您每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在问答环节，我们将揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果您想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场演出门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《恋爱岛》，紧张气氛正在加剧，兴奋感达到了狂热的程度。我们邀请到了顶级《恋爱岛》鉴赏家、爱好者、梗图制造者和全能专家凯蒂·霍兰德，她当然是顶级电视历史学家
and Spider-Man Tom Holland and um Katie we've done six of the Love Island contestants haven't we we've we've got some pretty big names unexpected names Byron, President Carter, Judas, Francis Stuart, Marcia Williams. And that's it, isn't it? And Leila Montez. Leila Montez. And Tom, you're due to nominate your next. Yeah, so I'm going to go for a man this time. I'm going to go for a lad.
和蜘蛛侠汤姆·霍兰德的女儿。凯蒂，我们已经完成了六位《恋爱岛》参赛者，对吧？我们有一些相当大的名字，意想不到的名字：拜伦、卡特总统、犹大、弗朗西丝·斯图尔特、玛西娅·威廉姆斯。就是这样，对吧？还有罗拉·蒙特兹。罗拉·蒙特兹。汤姆，该你提名下一个了。是的，这次我要选一个男性。我要选一个“小伙子”。
And this one is the lad of lads. So this is the funny one, the top lad who loves the lads, leader of the lads. And I've gone for General George Armstrong Custer, who, great 19th century general, 1839 to 76, great general, chiefly famous for having led the 7th Cavalry into the largest concentration of Native Americans gathered in the 19th century and being wiped out. Yeah, he says a great general, Tom. He's a terrible general but the thing about the thing about the battle of little bighorn is that it gave it gave those it gave the sioux and their allies probably the the single best moment of the 19th century um and i think that's what custer was all about he was about giving people a great time um people adored him he was nothing but trouble but people completely adored him so he was married he was married to libby and um she wrote about Custer that my husband used to tell me that he believed he was the happiest man on earth.
接下来这位是“小伙子中的小伙子”。他是个风趣的人，是热爱小伙子们、领导小伙子们的头号小伙子。我选的是乔治·阿姆斯特朗·卡斯特将军，这位伟大的19世纪将军，生于1839年，卒于1876年。他之所以出名，主要是因为他率领第七骑兵团冲进了19世纪规模最大的美洲原住民聚集地，结果全军覆没。是的，汤姆，你说他是一位伟大的将军。他其实是个糟糕的将军，但小大角战役的意义在于，它给了苏族及其盟友可能是19世纪最辉煌的时刻。我认为这就是卡斯特的全部意义所在，他就是为了让人们度过一段美好时光。人们崇拜他，虽然他只会惹麻烦，但人们对他崇拜得五体投地。他结了婚，妻子是利比。利比曾写道，卡斯特告诉她，他相信自己是世界上最幸福的人。
And I cannot help thinking that he was. Everything he did, he loved. He loved being in the cavalry. He loved having fun. who was in command of the Native American forces at the Battle of Little Bighorn said that he'd been told that when Custer died, he killed a man as he died, and then he laughed. So his very last thing was to kill someone and then laugh, which basically sums Custer up. And the whole course of his career was a kind of constant succession of scrapes, jams and and then people adored him so much that they would let him get out so he was at west point he came bottom at west point he was he he got kind of
我禁不住认为他确实如此。他热爱他所做的一切。他热爱骑兵生涯，热爱享乐。在小大角战役中指挥美洲原住民部队的人说，有人告诉他，卡斯特死时杀了一个人，然后大笑起来。所以他人生最后的一件事就是杀人然后大笑，这基本上概括了卡斯特的一生。他整个职业生涯就是一连串不断的麻烦和困境，但人们太崇拜他了，总是让他脱身。他在西点军校时成绩垫底，还因为……
court-martialed because he was supposed to be on sentry duty and he went off and got on a kind of lad's piss up in the the local town but everyone liked him so much that they let him off then the civil war happened and he was absolutely brilliant in the Civil War. He had these kind of golden ringlets. He loads of cavalry dash. He charged around. And again, everybody adored him. At the end of the Civil War, he was the youngest general ever in the US Army. And from that point on, he went out to the Great Plains and he just gallivanted around. His superiors would say, go and do this. He'd go off. He traveled everywhere with a team of Irish wolfhounds. And so if he kind of saw a deer or a buffalo, he'd go charging off after them and completely leave his troops stranded. And there was one occasion where
他本该站岗却溜出去在当地小镇参加小伙子们的狂欢，结果被送上军事法庭，但因为大家都太喜欢他了，所以放过了他。后来内战爆发，他在内战中表现得非常出色。他留着那种金色的卷发，充满骑兵的冲劲，四处冲锋。同样，每个人都崇拜他。内战结束时，他是美国陆军史上最年轻的将军。从那时起，他去了大平原，就开始四处游荡。上级让他去执行任务，他却跑了。他带着一群爱尔兰猎狼犬到处旅行，如果看到鹿或水牛，他就会冲过去追赶，完全把部队丢在一边。有一次……
a whole load of soldiers went out to find him, got ambushed by Native Americans. They had their eyeballs taken out and put on rocks. They had their testicles cut off and put in their mouths. Custer was told about this. And instead of feeling guilty about it, he went, how exciting for them. That must have been so exciting for them to be stalked and killed. What a thrill. And so that's basically what he is. Everything is a laugh. It's a thrill and so that was basic that's basically what he is everything is a laugh it's a thrill it's excitement and and people cannot help but forgiving him for all the kind of terrible scrapes that he gets into tom i'm not i'm not i'm not going to try and torpedo custer's chances because i know you want him to do well but i'm not right in thinking that by the
一大群士兵出去找他，结果遭到了美洲原住民的伏击。他们的眼珠被挖出来放在石头上，睾丸被割下来塞进嘴里。卡斯特得知此事后，非但没有感到内疚，反而说：“这对他们来说多刺激啊。被跟踪和杀害一定让他们感到非常刺激。真是太惊险了。”这基本上就是他的为人。一切都是笑话，是刺激。这就是他的为人，一切都是笑话，是刺激，是兴奋。人们忍不住原谅他所陷入的所有可怕困境。汤姆，我不是要破坏卡斯特的机会，因为我知道你想让他表现好，但我没说错吧，到……
time of little bighorn a he's a busted flush b he's starting to lose his hair i think which is surely a love island problem yeah i mean isn't there a counter argument he's actually a terrible general yeah he's a terrible general i i when i said great i mean great in the kind of love island sense that he looks like a general okay so not if he's losing his hair not if the ringlet yeah but but but he's entering it at the stage where in the words of one admirer, he is as beautiful as Absalom with his yellow curls. Okay, well. So he's a lad. Yeah, he does sound a lad.
小大角战役时，他已经是个过气人物了，而且我记得他开始脱发了，这在《恋爱岛》里肯定是个问题。是的，难道没有反面论点吗？他其实是个糟糕的将军。是的，他是个糟糕的将军。我刚才说他伟大，是指在《恋爱岛》那种意义上的伟大，因为他看起来像个将军。好吧，如果他脱发就不行了，如果他留着卷发……是的，但他正处于那个阶段，用一位崇拜者的话说，他像押沙龙一样美丽，留着金色的卷发。好吧，那他是个小伙子。是的，他听起来确实是个小伙子。
How do you think he'd do, Katie? Well, I feel like the fact that he's not a great general doesn't really matter because they mention their jobs in the first week and then it doesn't really come up. He's not there to fight the Sioux, is he? Well, also, I feel like he'd bring it into the games he'd use like you know general um imagery to rally the troops rally his lads um i think he'd do really well um i mean he'd love all the games he'd love you know he'd be playing pranks he'd be stealing people's speedos and all that you know just be non-stop bants i feel like he'd he'd put on the lady's fake tan just to see how it suited his golden locks he would do you know what he'd be he'd be general banter he would he really would i love him already all right okay
凯蒂，你觉得他表现会如何？我觉得他是不是伟大的将军并不重要，因为他们在第一周提到自己的工作，之后就不会再提了。他去那里又不是为了和苏族打仗，对吧？而且，我觉得他会把那种将军的形象带到游戏中，用来团结大家，团结他的小伙子们。我觉得他会表现得很好。他会喜欢所有的游戏，他会搞恶作剧，偷别人的泳裤之类的，总之就是不停地开玩笑。我觉得他会涂上女士的仿晒霜，看看适不适合他那金色的头发。你知道吗，他会是“玩笑将军”，他真的会。我已经爱上他了。好吧，好的。
well i've got so my other female contestant who deep down i think should win okay see i'm not gonna put the pressure on you. I think she should win. She's born in 500, about 500 AD, maybe from Syria. Maybe she's from Cyprus. She's the daughter of a dancer and an actress, and her name is Theodora. And she rises from humble beginnings to become Empress of Rome. Now, the thing about Theodora,
好的，我还有另一位女性参赛者，我觉得她内心深处应该获胜。好吧，我不会给你施加压力。我觉得她应该赢。她出生于公元500年左右，可能来自叙利亚，也可能来自塞浦路斯。她是舞女和女演员的女儿，名字叫狄奥多拉。她从卑微的出身崛起，最终成为了罗马皇后。关于狄奥多拉，
so she ends up marrying the Emperor Justinian, and Justinian and Theodora are probably the single most famous couple to have ruled the Eastern Roman Empire. So that's the successor state. Well, it's not the successor state. It's the continuation of the Roman Empire in the East, Byzantium, as it's called. They're one of the two or three most famous imperial couples of all time.
她最终嫁给了查士丁尼皇帝，查士丁尼和狄奥多拉可能是统治东罗马帝国最著名的夫妇。那是继任国家。好吧，这不是继任国家，而是罗马帝国在东方的延续，也就是所谓的拜占庭。他们是有史以来最著名的两三对帝国夫妇之一。
Theodora is a formidable character. So when these riots in Constantinople, after the chariot racing, the so-called Nica riots, when people are shouting Nica, Nica, sort of victory, victory, and smashing everything up and rampaging through Constantinople,
狄奥多拉是一个令人敬畏的人物。当君士坦丁堡发生骚乱时，在赛车比赛之后，所谓的“尼卡”暴动，人们高喊“尼卡，尼卡”，也就是“胜利，胜利”，到处打砸抢，在君士坦丁堡横行霸道时，
and the emperor is considering fleeing. It's Theodora who famously stiffens his resolve by saying, the purple, the imperial purple cloak, makes the best kind of funeral shroud. In other words, I'd rather die an empress than live as a commoner. And they stay and they kill everybody and survive. But the thing about Theodora is Theodora herself had been an actress and a dancer before she became Empress.
皇帝正在考虑逃跑。正是狄奥多拉坚定了他留下的决心，她说：“紫色，帝王的紫色斗篷，是最好的寿衣。”换句话说，我宁愿作为皇后死去，也不愿作为平民活着。于是他们留了下来，杀光了所有人并活了下来。但狄奥多拉的问题在于，她在成为皇后之前曾是一名演员和舞女。
So that scandalized the kind of old elite of the court. And she is the subject of one of the raciest and most incendiary biographies ever written, The Secret History, by a man called Procopius, who had been a courtier and had sort of fallen out with the imperial couple. And he fills it with this sort of, frankly, quite pornographic stuff about Theodora's past. So he says, before she was empress, her venal charms were abandoned to a promiscuous crowd of citizens and strangers of every night and of every position the fortunate
这让宫廷里的旧精英阶层感到震惊。她是史上最生动、最煽动性的传记之一《秘史》的主角，作者是一个叫普罗科匹厄斯的男人，他曾是朝臣，后来与这对帝国夫妇闹翻了。他在书中写满了关于狄奥多拉过去的、坦率地说相当色情的内容。他说，在她成为皇后之前，她的肉体魅力被随意地献给了一群形形色色的市民和陌生人，无论昼夜，无论地位高低。
lover who had been promised a night of enjoyment was often driven from her bed by a stronger or well or more wealthy favorite which is very love island procopia says often when she was alone with other actors she would undress in their midst and arch her and arch her back provocatively advertising like a peacock, both to those who had had experience of her and to those who had not yet had that privilege, her trained suppleness, which I think is also very Lavardian behaviour. Yeah, that is.
那个被承诺享受一夜欢愉的幸运情人，往往会被一个更强壮或更富有的人从她的床上赶走。这非常《恋爱岛》。普罗科匹厄斯说，当她和其他演员独处时，她经常在他们中间脱掉衣服，挑逗性地拱起背，像孔雀一样炫耀，无论是对那些有过经验的人，还是对那些还没享受过这种特权的人，展示她训练有素的柔韧性，我觉得这也是非常《恋爱岛》的行为。是的，确实是。
Often she would go picnicking with ten young men or more in the flower of their strength and virility and dallied with them all the whole night through. And when they wearied of the sport, she would approach their servants, perhaps 30 in number, and engage with each of these. And even thus, she found no allayment of her craving. And though, now I apologize to some listeners for this,
她经常和十个或更多的年轻男子一起去野餐，他们正值精力旺盛的年纪，她整晚都与他们调情。当他们对这种运动感到厌倦时，她会去找他们的仆人，大约有30人，并与他们每个人纠缠。即便如此，她也无法满足自己的渴望。虽然，现在我向一些听众道歉，
although she flung wide three gates to the ambassadors of Cupid, she lamented that nature had not similarly unlocked the straits of her bosomed that nature had not similarly unlocked the streets of her bosom so that she might there have contrived a further welcome to his emissaries so there's a lot of stuff like this and there's also some carry on with geese isn't there tom there is so so there aren't any there aren't any geese in the i suppose it could be couldn't there on it was my pleasure island so i can pleasure island so you could have them okay so so so she did she did stuff with geese i don't think would
虽然她为丘比特的使者敞开了三道大门，但她感叹大自然没有同样解锁她胸怀的狭窄通道，这样她就能在那里为他的使者安排更多的欢迎。所以有很多这样的内容，还有一些关于鹅的事情，对吧，汤姆？确实有。所以，那里没有鹅。我想这可能是，不是吗？这是我的“享乐岛”，所以你可以有它们。好吧，所以她和鹅做了一些事。我不认为这会……
make it onto primetime tv yeah but did she was that a rumor well that's the question isn't it that's the nature of this is the nature of that's the question and reality tv in the age of social media isn't it we don't know what's true and what's not and and also fair to point out that she does end up becoming a saint. So it'll be interesting to see which side of her character she brings out. The side that does things with geese
出现在黄金时段的电视上。是的，但那是谣言吗？好吧，这就是问题所在，不是吗？这就是社交媒体时代真人秀的本质。我们不知道什么是真，什么是假。而且值得指出的是，她最终成为了一名圣人。所以看看她会展现出她性格的哪一面会很有趣。是那个和鹅做事的她，
or the side that just spends the whole time in church praying. Because she's very religious, isn't she, Tom? She ends up very religious, yeah. So I think there's a lot going on with her and frankly, Katie, I'll be astounded if she doesn't win. I'll be shocked. I do think she's the most interesting one. She kind of reminds me of Molly May in season five.
还是那个整天在教堂祈祷的她？因为她非常虔诚，不是吗，汤姆？她最终变得非常虔诚，是的。所以我认为她身上有很多故事，坦率地说，凯蒂，如果她不赢，我会感到震惊。我会很惊讶。我确实认为她是其中最有趣的一个。她让我想起了第五季的莫莉·梅。
Does she? Did Molly? Was she friends with geese? Well, I don't know. There's just quite a lot to say. Because I think the actress background is quite interesting. Yeah, the arching the back, all that stuff. So Molly May was an influencer before she joined Love Island.
是吗？莫莉是吗？她和鹅是朋友吗？好吧，我不知道。只是有很多话要说。因为我觉得演员背景很有趣。是的，拱起背，所有那些东西。所以莫莉·梅在加入《恋爱岛》之前就是个网红。
And so I think people had a perception of her that she was in it to win. Right. That she was good at playing up to the cameras. So maybe that would be Theodora's criticism on Twitter. I think she would. Yes. Some people might. Well,
所以我认为人们对她有一种看法，觉得她是冲着赢去的。对吧。她很擅长在镜头前表演。所以也许这就是推特上对狄奥多拉的批评。我想她会。是的。有些人可能会。好吧，
obviously the Procopius took a great dislike to her and I was basically just making it up I think I think sort of Guardian readers will take against her because Procopius would have been a Guardian reading, wouldn't he Tom? No, he's the Daily Mail, he's just making stuff up No, Procopius is the Metropolitan Elite
显然普罗科匹厄斯非常讨厌她，我基本上认为他只是在编造。我想《卫报》的读者会反对她，因为普罗科匹厄斯会是个《卫报》读者，对吧，汤姆？不，他是《每日邮报》的，他只是在编造。不，普罗科匹厄斯是都市精英。
No, no, no, no he's tabloid, he's at pure tabloid tabloid is at pure tabloid press i think this is that's fake news right that's okay all right so um i've also got an ancient member of royalty uh so i'm going for uh it's another woman justifiably angry jilted one almost always a woman will pull her ex for a chat and berate him in front of everyone he won't care so i have gone for olympias uh fourth century queen from a pyrus who uh ended up marrying philip of macedon and is the mother of alexander the great uh and she had a tempestuous relationship with philip who was not a good boy, was constantly cheating on her. And Olympias was
不，不，不，他是小报，他是纯粹的小报。我认为这是假新闻，对吧？好吧，好的。所以，我还有一位古代皇室成员。我选的是另一位女性，一位正当愤怒的被抛弃者。几乎总是女性会把前任拉出来聊天，并在所有人面前斥责他，他根本不在乎。所以我选了奥林匹亚丝，来自伊庇鲁斯的四世纪女王，她最终嫁给了马其顿的腓力，是亚历山大大帝的母亲。她和腓力有着动荡的关系，腓力不是个好东西，一直在欺骗她。而奥林匹亚丝是一个……
a terrifyingly angry person, very, very formidable person. You wouldn't really want to annoy her, but Philip did. And so there are all kinds of rumours that in the end, she ended up having him assassinated, which would be a kind of extreme way to win love Island. But I think Olympias, you know, if that's what she decided it took, she'd do it. And other,
极其愤怒的人，非常、非常可怕的人。你真的不想惹她，但腓力惹了。所以有各种传言说，最终她策划了对他的暗杀，这在《恋爱岛》中算是一种极端的获胜方式。但我认为奥林匹亚丝，你知道，如果她认为有必要，她会这么做的。还有，
her other party trick. And again, perhaps this is something that would enable her to go directly in, in up against Theodora is that she's supposed to have gone to bed with giant snakes. Yeah. So I don't know how that would go down with the watching fans. But so she would offer fans snakes
她的另一个拿手好戏。同样，也许这能让她直接与狄奥多拉抗衡，那就是据说她曾与巨蛇同床共枕。是的。所以我不知道这在观众中会引起什么反响。但她会给粉丝们提供蛇，
and an ability to eliminate anyone who annoyed her. Which was her reputation that she was a spurned woman and she never got him back really in the end. Yeah. Well, he had multiple wives didn't he was yeah he was endlessly marrying um uh other queens and also he he played the dirty trick so so um Olympias was the the sister of the king of Epirus and so she could always rely on him but Philip kind of stabbed her in the back by sending off their daughter to to marry him so it was all very incestuous and devious and treacherous so he had the last laugh really no because he
以及消除任何惹恼她的人的能力。这就是她的名声，她是一个被抛弃的女人，最终并没有真正挽回他。是的。好吧，他有很多妻子，不是吗？是的，他不断地娶其他女王。而且他还玩了卑鄙的手段。所以奥林匹亚丝是伊庇鲁斯国王的妹妹，所以她总是可以依靠他，但腓力通过把他们的女儿送去嫁给他来背后捅她一刀。所以这一切都非常乱伦、阴险和背叛。所以他真的笑到了最后吗？不，因为他……
ended up dead and and she uh she she survived him so i offer i offer you olympias yeah i think she's she's um controversial isn't she yeah i think she might pull people's backs up the wrong way. The snake stuff is a problem, I think. Yeah, I don't think she's going to do that well. Okay, well. Sorry. Okay, no, fine. Have we just got one left?
最终死了，而她活了下来。所以我向你推荐奥林匹亚丝。是的，我觉得她很有争议，不是吗？是的，我觉得她可能会让人们反感。蛇的事情是个问题，我想。是的，我不认为她会表现得很好。好吧，抱歉。好吧，没关系。我们只剩下一个了吗？
One left, yeah. So I'm in this to win this, actually. I want to see my contestants win. I can tell. So there's one category left, which is producer's favourite. Always very likeable and unproblematic. And so I thought I'd go for somebody very monogamous, uxorious, who pairs up quickly and then sticks by their partner
只剩一个了，是的。其实我是冲着赢来的。我想看到我的参赛者获胜。我看得出来。所以还剩一个类别，那就是“制片人的最爱”。总是非常讨人喜欢，没有问题。所以我决定选一个非常专一、宠妻的人，他能很快配对，然后一直陪伴着伴侣，
for the rest of the competition. Somebody who a lot of Restor's History audience, you know, who they'll already like because they know him as a great man of history. And trust him. And they trust him. Yeah, they trust him. And he's, of course,
直到比赛结束。一个很多《Restor's History》观众已经喜欢的人，因为他们知道他是一位伟大的历史人物。并且信任他。他们信任他。是的，他们信任他。他当然是……
former Prime Minister Stanley Baldwin. Yeah. So Stanley Baldwin, Katie, as I'm sure you know, you don't need me to tell you because I know Stanley Baldwin's name will trip off your tongue. Stanley Baldwin was three times Prime Minister in the 1920s and 1930s.
前首相斯坦利·鲍德温。是的。斯坦利·鲍德温，凯蒂，我相信你知道，不需要我告诉你，因为我知道斯坦利·鲍德温的名字会脱口而出。斯坦利·鲍德温在20世纪20年代和30年代三次担任首相。
Criminally forgotten now, it pains me to say. A man of the Midlands. He appears very stolid, kind of paternalistic, conservative. He gave a tenth of his fortune to pay off the national debt anonymously at the end of the First World War.
现在被罪恶地遗忘了，我很难过。一个来自米德兰兹的人。他看起来非常稳重、慈父般、保守。第一次世界大战结束时，他匿名捐出了自己十分之一的财产来偿还国债。
So he's an incredibly kind man, Katie. And I think that will count for a lot with the fans. I think what will also count with the fans is he's not boring, so he's not Jimmy Carter Jimmy Carter has committed lust in his heart as we know Stanley was almost kicked out of Harrow as a boy for writing his own pornography and then I'd forgotten this that when he then went
所以他是一个非常善良的人，凯蒂。我认为这对粉丝来说意义重大。我认为对粉丝来说同样重要的是他不无聊，所以他不是吉米·卡特。正如我们所知，吉米·卡特心中有淫念。斯坦利小时候差点被哈罗公学开除，因为他写了自己的色情作品。然后我忘了这一点，当他后来……
on to Cambridge where he got third his time at Trinity College, Cambridge, was blighted by the fact that when he went to Cambridge, as soon as he arrived at Trinity, they said, oh, we've got a new master of the college. And to his horror, the new master of the college was the headmaster of Harrow. Oh, that's awful. Who had never forgiven him for writing this porn. And basically was always glaring at him
去了剑桥大学，拿到了三等学位。他在剑桥三一学院的时光被一件事情毁了，那就是当他刚到三一学院时，他们说：“哦，我们有了一位新的学院院长。”令他惊恐的是，新院长竟然是哈罗公学的校长。哦，那太糟糕了。他从未原谅他写色情作品的事。基本上总是怒视着他，
or giving him, you you know muttering under his breath as he passed Baldwin so that was that was a problem for Baldwin um but one more thing about Baldwin which I think will endear him to the fans is Baldwin and his wife Lucy had I think six children like I remember but one of them Oliver who also became an MP became an MP for the Labour Party and was gay and lived with his friend Johnny, his partner, all his days. And Stanley, defying the conventions of the times, was absolutely fine with this, would write letters to them as a couple, have them over for dinner, all this kind of thing. Very, very progressive, good behaviour.
或者在他经过时对他嘟囔。所以这对鲍德温来说是个问题。但关于鲍德温还有一件事，我认为会让他受到粉丝的喜爱，那就是鲍德温和他的妻子露西有六个孩子，我记得。但其中一个叫奥利弗，他也成为了议员，是工党议员，而且是同性恋，他一生都和他的朋友约翰尼，也就是他的伴侣住在一起。斯坦利无视当时的传统，对此完全没意见，会以伴侣的身份给他们写信，请他们来吃晚饭，所有这些。非常、非常进步，表现很好。
Now, on top of that, we need to talk about his love life. So this will definitely, I think this actually will tempt Tom away from some of Tom's own contenders. Stanley met his wife, Lucy. Lucy, when you look at pictures of her, is not a natural Love Island contestant. I think it's fair to say she's quite a large woman, but she's photographed in later life.
现在，除此之外，我们需要谈谈他的爱情生活。所以我认为这实际上会诱使汤姆放弃他自己的一些竞争者。斯坦利遇到了他的妻子露西。露西，当你看到她的照片时，她不是那种天生的《恋爱岛》参赛者。我认为公平地说，她是个相当壮硕的女人，但那是她晚年的照片。
So let's give her the benefit of the doubt. But he met Lucy, and he he was as a young man. And what literally bowled him over was that when he first laid eyes upon her, she was bowling in a cricket match. Wow. Because she was a very, very keen cricketer. She played for the white Heather club,
所以让我们给她一点宽容。但他遇到了露西，他当时还是个年轻人。真正让他倾倒的是，当他第一次看到她时，她正在板球比赛中投球。哇。因为她是一个非常、非常热衷的板球运动员。她为“白石楠俱乐部”效力，
which is, I think the first women's one or one of the first women's cricket clubs, she was an excellent batsman or batswoman. Her average, Tom, do you know what her average was? Yeah. I'm asking you to guess. Oh, 36. No, her batting average was 62.
我想这是第一个女子板球俱乐部之一。她是一位出色的击球手。汤姆，你知道她的平均分是多少吗？是的。我让你猜。哦，36。不，她的击球平均分是62。
Wow. She was higher at the time than the top professional men's player. So she was an absolutely first-class cricketer. Do you know, she will bowl over the fans dominic stanley baldwin was immensely impressed by her he would take the train to go and watch her play cricket and then when he will take the train home home again on the way home he would get off katie at every stop to send her a telegram saying how much he was missing her okay yeah stanley baldwin i think mean, he's not in this for the money because he's giving his money away.
哇。在当时，她比顶尖的职业男选手还要高。所以她是一位绝对一流的板球运动员。你知道吗，她会迷倒粉丝的，多米尼克。斯坦利·鲍德温对她印象深刻。他会坐火车去看她打板球，然后在回家的路上，凯蒂，他会在每一站下车，给她发一封电报，说他有多想她。好吧，是的。斯坦利·鲍德温，我想，他不是为了钱，因为他把钱都捐了。
He's in this for love. But he didn't adequately prepare us for the Second World War. So there is that. That is a minor, no. So that is more fake news. There is that. So that is perhaps a problem. I feel like you're just jealous because Dominic's choices are so good.
他是为了爱。但他没有充分让我们为第二次世界大战做好准备。所以确实有这一点。那是一个小小的，不。所以那更多是假新闻。确实有这一点。所以那也许是个问题。我觉得你只是嫉妒，因为多米尼克的选择太好了。
No, I'm not in it to win. I'm not in it to win. I'm in it to provide the fans with the best show. That's the thing. So just before you choose who couples up with who, we just need to run through who looks good in skimpy swimwear because that's key, isn't it? Yeah.
不，我不是为了赢。我不是为了赢。我是为了给粉丝们提供最好的节目。就是这样。所以在你选择谁和谁配对之前，我们只需要过一遍谁穿紧身泳装好看，因为那很关键，不是吗？是的。
Okay, so who have we got we so we got um little byron byron will look good yeah general custer general custer would look good jimmy carter not good jimmy carter probably not not good he's a bit stupid scrawny yeah a bit scrawny uh stanley baldwin terror he wouldn't look good i mean he looks good in a tweed suit and a hat but he's not going to look good in speedos is he i mean even you would admit that dominic i would i would admit that and who was the fifth man i can't remember i have i have no idea but he'd probably look quite good well that's
好的，我们有谁？我们有……小拜伦。拜伦会很好看。是的。卡斯特将军。卡斯特将军会很好看。吉米·卡特，不好看。吉米·卡特可能不好看。他有点笨，瘦骨嶙峋。是的，有点瘦骨嶙峋。斯坦利·鲍德温，天哪。他不会好看的。我的意思是，他穿粗花呢西装和戴帽子很好看，但他穿泳裤不会好看，对吧？即使是你也会承认这一点，多米尼克。我会承认的。第五个男人是谁？我不记得了。我不知道，但他可能看起来不错。好吧，那是……
i mean he's been roaming around galilee for three years so he's probably quite tanned tanned i think he'd look good i think he'd look good so uh and then the girls uh leila montes would obviously be sensational uh theodora would look sensational francis stewart would look sensational olympias would probably look frightening i just think there'd be something about how they would be. She'd probably have lots of menacing tattoos. And I can't remember who the fifth one was. Marcia Williams, Lady Fulmer. What would she look like? What would she look like twerking? I can't even speak. I'm laughing so much, also I've completely lost my voice okay so I think Marcy Williams
我的意思是，他在加利利游荡了三年，所以他可能晒得很黑。晒黑了。我觉得他会很好看。我觉得他会很好看。所以，然后是女孩们。萝拉·蒙特兹显然会非常轰动。狄奥多拉会看起来很轰动。弗朗西斯·斯图尔特会看起来很轰动。奥林匹亚丝可能会看起来很吓人。我只是觉得她们会有一种特别的感觉。她可能会有很多威胁性的纹身。我不记得第五个是谁了。玛西娅·威廉姆斯，福尔默夫人。她看起来会怎样？她跳电臀舞会是什么样子？我甚至说不出话来了。我笑得太厉害了，而且我完全失声了。好吧，所以我认为玛西娅·威廉姆斯……
probably is in the Stanley Baldwin category when it comes to the swimwear I don't think it's okay so Katie Dunn can you can you pair up those those 10 contenders so this is sort of week one is it hard um that's the fun of it isn't it okay so i think i do okay so i think instinctively byron and olympia pair up i think she'd i think she'd like she'd want him because he wants everyone else yeah and he would be awful for her he'd be awful and i so i think the producers would would make them get together through games. Excellent pairing. Yeah. Okay, I'm glad you thought that was an excellent pairing
在泳装方面可能属于斯坦利·鲍德温那一类。我不认为这没关系。好的，凯蒂·邓恩，你能把那10位竞争者配对吗？这是第一周，对吧？很难。嗯，这就是乐趣所在，不是吗？好的，我想我能行。所以我凭直觉认为拜伦和奥林匹亚丝配对。我想她会想要他，因为他想要其他人。是的，他会对她很糟糕。他会对她很糟糕。所以我认为制片人会通过游戏让他们在一起。绝佳的配对。是的。好的，我很高兴你认为那是一个绝佳的配对。
because I wasn't really sure. No, you're the arbiter. You choose. Okay. I think Theodora and Stanley Baldwin. Oh, yeah. That's my dream couple i'd like to have them over here dominic i i can't i mean that is so completely your dream pairing
因为我不太确定。不，你是裁判。你来选。好的。我认为狄奥多拉和斯坦利·鲍德温。哦，是的。那是我的梦想情侣。多米尼克，我想让他们来这里。我，我不能，我的意思是，那完全是你的梦想配对。
okay so theodora and stanley baldwin yeah okay good um so that's the second you need to say why or can i just just give you the pair yeah no yeah so that's as obvious i mean well yeah but but why do you think well why is it dominic's dream pet dream pairing because stanley baldwin's his hero and theodora is his um heroine oh i did it for you he's always loved them but why do you think that stanley baldwin and theodora would make a natural couple um because i think um they both have quite cheeky sides to them yeah that's one way of putting it okay yeah that's a good reason that's a good reason they're quite good at they're not they're they're pretty good people at monogamy yeah they're pretty good people. At monogamy, yeah.
好的，所以狄奥多拉和斯坦利·鲍德温。是的，好的，很好。所以那是第二个。你需要说为什么，还是我可以直接给你配对？是的，不，是的。所以那很明显。我的意思是，好吧，是的，但你为什么认为……好吧，为什么这是多米尼克的梦想配对？因为斯坦利·鲍德温是他的英雄，而狄奥多拉是他的女英雄。哦，我替你说了。他一直很爱他们。但你为什么认为斯坦利·鲍德温和狄奥多拉会成为自然的一对？嗯，因为我认为他们都有相当俏皮的一面。是的，这是一种说法。好的，是的，这是一个很好的理由。这是一个很好的理由。他们很擅长……他们，他们是相当擅长专一的人。是的，他们是相当好的人。在专一方面，是的。
They're heart of gold, heart of gold. Yeah. And I think Theodora would be, you know, Sandy Baldwin's a leader. She's good at helping a leader. I think people at first wouldn't trust her, that they would think she was just with him because everyone likes him and that it's a clear way to get money. You know, she's a shrewd intelligent and so
他们有金子般的心，金子般的心。是的。而且我认为狄奥多拉会是，你知道，斯坦利·鲍德温是一位领导者。她很擅长帮助领导者。我认为人们起初不会信任她，他们会认为她和他在一起只是因为大家都喜欢他，而且这是一种获得金钱的明确方式。你知道，她是一个精明、聪明的人，所以……
rather than married to someone who spends all her time playing cricket maybe if he's matched up with someone who could say you know rearm Yeah You're looking at a very different story the origins of the second world war with Theodore I think Theodore and Sani would be quite sweet together actually
与其嫁给一个整天打板球的人，也许如果他和一个能说“你知道，重新武装”的人配对，你会看到一个非常不同的故事。第二次世界大战的起源，和狄奥多拉在一起。我认为狄奥多拉和斯坦利在一起会很甜蜜。
Okay good Okay Marcy Williams I just don't know what to do with her Dora and Sani would be quite sweet together, actually. Okay, good. Okay. Marcy Williams, I just don't know what to do with her. Okay, I feel like Lola Montes and General Custer would have a good time. Yeah, I think they'd be. Definitely would. I can't believe I'm taking this sufficiently seriously, that I'm diligently noting down what you're saying.
好的，很好。好的，玛西娅·威廉姆斯，我只是不知道该拿她怎么办。狄奥多拉和斯坦利在一起会很甜蜜，其实。好的，很好。好的，玛西娅·威廉姆斯，我只是不知道该拿她怎么办。好的，我觉得萝拉·蒙特兹和卡斯特将军会玩得很开心。是的，我想他们会。绝对会。我不敢相信我把这事看得这么认真，我还在勤奋地记下你说的话。
Okay, so I think I agree. They completely go together. They are gin and tonic. Fourth couple? Okay, my fourth couple are Marcy Williams and Judas. Marcy Williams and Judas. Yes. I mean, that would be a toxic pairing, wouldn't it?
好的，所以我认为我同意。他们完全合得来。他们是金汤力。第四对？好的，我的第四对是玛西娅·威廉姆斯和犹大。玛西娅·威廉姆斯和犹大。是的。我的意思是，那会是一对有毒的配对，不是吗？
Well, if she's tapping a handbag and threatening to ring the Daily mail about him but i think because i think she'd be but i think she'd be intrigued by his motives and she'd say maybe we would be a good power couple i feel like they'd match in each other yeah let's join up and make some right yes and i think they tried to sabotage everyone it would yeah so they could win. But I'm not sure they'd make it to the fight well. I guess for the fans to say, isn't it? Well, it's for you to say, actually. And then I finally put Jimmy Carter and Francis Stewart.
嗯，如果她拿着手提包，威胁要给《每日邮报》打电话举报他。但我认为，因为我觉得她会被他的动机所吸引，她会说也许我们会成为一对很好的权力情侣。我觉得他们会互相匹配。是的，让我们联手做些正确的事。是的，而且我认为他们会试图破坏每个人。这会……是的，这样他们就能赢。但我不知道他们能不能撑到最后。我想这得由粉丝们来说，不是吗？好吧，其实得由你来说。最后我把吉米·卡特和弗朗西斯·斯图尔特配在一起。
Yeah, yeah, I could see that working. But they're both sweet people. But Jimmy Carter done very well for himself there, I think. Unaccountably well. Yeah. I think he'd very well for himself there, I think. Unaccountably well. Yeah. I think he'd be completely obsessed with her, but would be panicking. I think that's a very, very sweet pairing.
是的，是的，我能看出这行得通。但他们都是甜美的人。但吉米·卡特在那里表现得很好，我想。好得不可思议。是的，我想他在那里表现得很好，我想。好得不可思议。是的，我想他会完全迷恋她，但会感到恐慌。我认为那是一对非常、非常甜蜜的配对。
Right. But somebody has to go, right? They do. But Dominic and Katie, back me up here. Part of the complication is that you then bring new people into the mix, right? Yeah, exactly. So that's also part of it.
好的。但总得有人走，对吧？确实。但多米尼克和凯蒂，支持我。复杂的一部分是，你随后会引入新人，对吧？是的，完全正确。所以这也是其中的一部分。
They're parachuted in. So, Dominic, what I thought we should do is that we should, before Katie decides who gets thrown off, because we're going to have four couples that go up to the public vote. So one of these five couples needs to go. we do that let's introduce three lads and three babes in their in their their tight speedos and their bikinis to see whether katie thinks that any of these might be successful in in kind of worming their way in i've chosen three lads you've chosen three babes i'm gutted that you've incriminated me in this but go on yeah okay so the three lads that i've chosen and all of these are friends of the show so regular listeners podcast will will probably know who they are okay so the first the first person I'm introducing well actually they're a pair of lads they're good old they're friends the first one is Dietrich von Hülsen
他们是空降的。所以，多米尼克，我想我们应该做的是，在凯蒂决定谁被踢出去之前，因为我们将有四对情侣进入公众投票。所以这五对情侣中有一对需要走。在我们做那件事之前，让我们介绍三个小伙子和三个美女，穿着他们的紧身泳裤和比基尼，看看凯蒂是否认为他们中的任何一个能成功地钻进来。我选了三个小伙子，你选了三个美女。我很遗憾你把我牵扯进这件事里，但继续吧。是的，好的。所以我选的三个小伙子，他们都是节目的朋友，所以经常听播客的人可能知道他们是谁。好的，第一个人，其实他们是一对小伙子，他们是好朋友。第一个是迪特里希·冯·许尔森-
Heisler who Katie is the chief of the German general staff but is chiefly known for the way that he died so he was in a hunting lodge with the kaiser and a whole and all the top general german generals um the kaiser's feeling a bit down dietrich von hülsenhäseler goes out goes out of the room in mid-supper and suddenly bursts back in dressed in a tutu pirouettes does dance to the sugar plum fairy and then kills over dead now do you think that this would be a party trick that would appeal to any of any of the any of the girls in that we've got there i think oh because that reminds me very much of a moment in 2019 oh really well what 2019. Oh, really? What happened? Tell us. So there's a dancing challenge
海斯勒，凯蒂，他是德国总参谋长，但主要以他的死法而闻名。当时他和凯撒以及所有德国顶级将军在狩猎小屋里。凯撒心情有点低落，迪特里希·冯·许尔森-海斯勒在晚餐中途走出房间，突然冲了回来，穿着芭蕾舞裙，旋转着，跳着《糖果仙子》的舞，然后倒地身亡。现在你认为这会是一个吸引我们这里任何女孩的派对技巧吗？我想，哦，因为那让我想起了2019年的一个时刻。哦，真的吗？什么2019年。哦，真的吗？发生了什么？告诉我们。所以有一个舞蹈挑战，
where you have to try and get your partner's heart rate up. And it reminds me of Curtis a bit. So there's a couple of dancers in the mix. I mean, experienced dancers. Theodora Lola Montez. Maybe Lola Montez.
你必须尝试让你的伴侣心率加快。这让我想起了柯蒂斯。所以混合中有几个舞者。我的意思是，经验丰富的舞者。狄奥多拉，萝拉·蒙特兹。也许是萝拉·蒙特兹。
You think she'd ditch General Custer for Dietrich Graf von Hülsenhäseler? I'm not sure. I don't think she would. I don't think she would. Okay, well, listen, Katie, the two other lads who come in, the next one is Dietrich von Hülsenhäseler's friend, the Kaiser. Oh, gosh.
你认为她会为了迪特里希·格拉夫·冯·许尔森-海斯勒而甩掉卡斯特将军吗？我不确定。我不认为她会。我不认为她会。好的，好吧，听着，凯蒂，进来的另外两个小伙子，下一个是迪特里希·冯·许尔森-海斯勒的朋友，凯撒。哦，天哪。
But disaster, because he's come in in his tight speedos looking good, but he's wearing deck shoes. He's wearing deck shoes. They're the wrong shoes. He's got the wrong end of speedos looking good, but he's wearing deck shoes. He's wearing deck shoes. They're the wrong shoes. He's got the wrong end of the stick. Oh, no. But would the fact he's wearing deck shoes. Exactly.
但灾难发生了，因为他穿着紧身泳裤进来，看起来不错，但他穿着甲板鞋。他穿着甲板鞋。那是错误的鞋子。他搞错了……穿着紧身泳裤看起来不错，但他穿着甲板鞋。他穿着甲板鞋。那是错误的鞋子。他搞错了。哦，不。但如果他穿着甲板鞋呢？完全正确。
I mean, the wrong footwear. I don't know how that would play. What would Olympias or Marcio Williams. Okay. And the third friend of the show he's coming in is General Gordon. Yeah. Chinese Gordon. Great imperial hero in China,
我的意思是，错误的鞋子。我不知道那会怎么演。奥林匹亚丝或玛西娅·威廉姆斯会怎么想。好的。第三个节目的朋友进来了，是戈登将军。是的，中国戈登。中国伟大的帝国英雄，
in Khartoum, ends up dying there. But he's possibly not the ideal person to go on Love Island because it was said of him that the presence of ladies, especially fashionable ladies, filled him with uneasiness. And on one occasion, he went to the ballet in naples sat there for about five minutes was so appalled by uh by the spectacle of what the ballerinas were wearing that he stormed out crying you call that civilization so i i don't know whether you think any of those would would really i mean there's no obligation they're all really good i think they're really good choices but i don't think i think general g Gordon would have the same luck as Jimmy Carter,
在喀土穆，最终死在那里。但他可能不是去《恋爱岛》的理想人选，因为有人说，女士们，尤其是时髦女士们的存在，让他感到不安。有一次，他去那不勒斯看芭蕾舞，坐在那里大约五分钟，对芭蕾舞演员的穿着感到非常震惊，以至于他哭着冲了出去，说：“你管这叫文明？”所以我不知道你是否认为他们中的任何一个真的会……我的意思是，没有义务，他们都是非常好的选择，但我认为戈登将军会和吉米·卡特有同样的运气，
really. I think they'd make him go on loads of dates and he'd find it horrible. He'd hate it. He'd really hate it. Some people walk out, don't they? Yeah, someone walked out last week, actually, because he thought, this isn't for me. I see General Gordon as somebody who would walk out quite quickly. Yeah, I would agree with
真的。我想他们会让他去约会很多次，他会觉得很可怕。他会讨厌它。他真的会讨厌它。有些人会走掉，不是吗？是的，上周确实有人走掉了，因为他觉得，这不适合我。我把戈登将军看作是一个会很快走掉的人。是的，我同意……
that, Dominic. Yeah, I think he would walk out very quickly. So probably none of them, then. That's disappointing. Yeah, I would agree with that, Dominic. Yeah, I think he would walk out very quickly. So probably none of them then. That's disappointing. Well, I don't think deck shoes are enough to get you booted off the island, but I don't think instinctively, I don't think that none of these people are speaking to me as his soulmate.
多米尼克。是的，我想他会很快走掉。所以可能他们一个都不行。那很令人失望。是的，我同意多米尼克。是的，我想他会很快走掉。所以可能他们一个都不行。那很令人失望。好吧，我不认为甲板鞋足以让你被踢出岛，但我凭直觉认为，我不认为这些人中有人能作为他的灵魂伴侣与我对话。
Okay, okay, fine. Okay, so Dominic, the three girls. So the three ladies. So I think it's fair to say, isn't it, Katie, that Love Island is a story like all reality TV shows of heroes and villains, and the producers like to create villains. So I thought I'd bring on one of history's great undisputed villains, and that is the writer Virginia Woolf.
好的，好的，没关系。好的，多米尼克，三个女孩。所以三位女士。所以我认为公平地说，凯蒂，就像所有真人秀节目一样，《恋爱岛》是一个关于英雄和恶棍的故事，制片人喜欢创造恶棍。所以我决定带上一位历史上伟大的、无可争议的恶棍，那就是作家弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫。
So Mrs. Woolf enters the house. I mean, people will know her. Modernist writer, author of Mrs. Dalloway, To the Lighthouse and so on. Also a towering world-class snob who was writing her diary about how she hates her servants and wishes they were all dead and they're horribly fat and common
所以伍尔夫夫人进入了房子。我的意思是，人们会认识她。现代主义作家，《达洛维夫人》、《到灯塔去》等等的作者。也是一位顶尖的世界级势利小人，她在日记里写着她有多讨厌她的仆人，希望他们都死掉，他们又胖又俗气，
and all this sort of thing. Well, she wouldn't have to worry about fat people, would she? No, that's not going to be a problem. But the issue of, I mean, Theodora is from the sort of wrong side of the tracks lola montez um virginia wolf i personally i see her trying to form an alliance early on with marcia williams they both have a sort of equine look yes um so they might bond they might bond over that would i mean katie the decision is yours I think Virginia Woolf would get on quite well with Judas oh Dominic but you may disagree I mean she hated Stanley Baldwin by the way there was bad blood
所有这些。好吧，她不必担心胖子，不是吗？不，那不会是个问题。但问题是，我的意思是，狄奥多拉来自那种错误的轨道，萝拉·蒙特兹，弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫，我个人看到她试图在早期与玛西娅·威廉姆斯结盟，她们都有点马的样子。是的，所以她们可能会建立联系，她们可能会因为这一点而建立联系。我的意思是，凯蒂，决定权在你。我认为弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫会和犹大相处得很好。哦，多米尼克，但你可能不同意。我的意思是，顺便说一句，她讨厌斯坦利·鲍德温，那里有积怨，
there because Stanley Baldwin oh you know represents everything that Mrs. Woolf despises in the politics of the 1920s so the producers know that of course so that's almost like bringing on an ex or something so when she enters the show. When you've got bad blood before, yeah. I think the cameras are on Stanley Baldwin's face. Yeah. Rolling his eyes. Oh my God, it's Virginia.
因为斯坦利·鲍德温，哦，你知道，代表了伍尔夫夫人在20世纪20年代政治中所鄙视的一切。所以制片人当然知道这一点，所以这几乎就像带上一个前任之类的。所以当她进入节目时。当你之前有积怨时，是的。我想摄像机都在斯坦利·鲍德温的脸上。是的。翻着白眼。哦，天哪，是弗吉尼亚。
Okay, who else, Dominic? So Virginia Woolf, my next one, I have to say Tom was slightly instrumental in some of these choices. The next one is another great fan favourite, though some people might say another villainess, somebody who's going to have a little bit of an issue possibly with Marcia Williams, and that's the late Baroness Thatcher.
好的，还有谁，多米尼克？所以弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫，我的下一个，我必须说汤姆在这些选择中起了一点作用。下一个是另一位伟大的粉丝最爱，尽管有些人可能会说是另一个女恶棍，一个可能和玛西娅·威廉姆斯有点问题的人，那就是已故的撒切尔夫人。
So Mrs. Thatcher, now she's an interesting one because, A, she loves dancing. She's well up for the dancing challenges because when she visited the White House in, I think, 1981, Dennis and the ambassador and so on had to basically prize her away from receptions because she wanted to keep dancing to the small hours and actually when they got to new york at the end of the trip she again said at the end of one evening i'd love to now go dancing and they were like no no prime minister you can't go dancing
所以撒切尔夫人，她很有趣，因为，第一，她喜欢跳舞。她很乐意参加舞蹈挑战，因为当她在1981年访问白宫时，丹尼斯和大使等人基本上不得不把她从招待会上拉开，因为她想一直跳舞到凌晨。事实上，当他们在旅行结束时到达纽约时，她又在一天晚上结束时说：“我现在想去跳舞。”他们说：“不，不，首相，你不能去跳舞。”
so that's an issue so but she wouldn't like sitting around by swimming pool would she no because she hated holidays this is problem. She was always trying to work. She would undoubtedly bring work with her. I worry that she would argue with Marcia Williams a lot about inflation or something. I mean, she hated, she didn't get on with Jimmy Carter. So again. Oh, I was about to say maybe that could be a... He was teased a teetotaler.
所以那是个问题。但她不喜欢坐在游泳池边，不是吗？不，因为她讨厌假期。这是个问题。她总是试图工作。她无疑会随身携带工作。我担心她会因为通货膨胀之类的东西和玛西娅·威廉姆斯吵架。我的意思是，她讨厌，她和吉米·卡特相处得不好。所以又是。哦，我正要说也许那可能是一个……他是一个滴酒不沾的人。
She likes a drink of an evening. She went to the White House and had a terrible time when he was the host but they're both quite exorius aren't they so well they are they are although she had an eye for kind of raffish slightly sleazy lounge lizard men maybe she loves that she would love byron she'd she hated jimmy carter because he's boring she'd love byron'd love Custer. I actually think deep down she would have a slight soft spot for Judas. Gosh, yeah. No, she's very devout. But the Methodism is an issue there.
她晚上喜欢喝一杯。她去过白宫，在他做东的时候度过了一段糟糕的时光，但他们俩都相当放荡，不是吗？嗯，他们确实是，尽管她对那种轻浮、稍微有点卑劣的浪荡公子情有独钟。也许她喜欢那样，她会喜欢拜伦，她会喜欢卡斯特。我其实觉得在内心深处，她会对犹大有一点好感。天哪，是的。不，她非常虔诚。但卫理公会教派在那里是个问题。
No, I don't think so. I think Virginia Woolf I don't think is strong enough to tear apart Marcia Williams and Judas for me. Oh, really? Okay. And what about your third choice, Dominic? Yeah, well, what Katie's thinking about, Mrs. Thatcher, the third choice, a real favourite of Tom's this,
不，我不这么认为。我觉得弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫对我来说不足以拆散玛西娅·威廉姆斯和犹大。哦，真的吗？好吧。那你的第三个选择呢，多米尼克？嗯，好吧，凯蒂在想撒切尔夫人，第三个选择，汤姆真正喜欢的一个，
and I have to say he put me up to this. Yeah, I did. It appears to be the late Empress Poppea, wife of the Emperor Nero. But it must become quite quickly apparent, Tom, if there's this whole swimwear stuff and all this business, that actually this is Nero's it's a slave isn't he he's a freedman he's a free boy a freed boy called Sporus who Nero has had castrated
我不得不说，是他怂恿我选这个的。是的，我选的。这似乎是已故的波培娅皇后，尼禄皇帝的妻子。但汤姆，如果这里有这么多泳装之类的东西，很快就会变得显而易见，这其实是尼禄的……他是个奴隶，对吧？他是个被释放的奴隶，一个叫斯波鲁斯的被释放的男孩，尼禄让人把他阉割了
to make him look like Poppea which I think is something perhaps that the Love Island production hasn't yet investigated so we're ahead of the curve so They definitely haven't, no. So they haven't introduced a eunuch. So this is very progressive. I mean there's probably going to be complaints on social media about Love Island going woke. I know exactly what would happen to Sporus actually. That's the one I do know. What's going to happen? I think Sporus and Byron will get together. So what happens to Olympias? Leaving Olympias jilted and booted off the island. Because if you're single, you can't survive. Olympias booted off the island. But hold on, at this point,
让他看起来像波培娅，我觉得这可能是《恋爱岛》制作组还没研究过的事情，所以我们走在了前面。他们肯定还没研究过，没有。所以他们还没引入太监。这非常前卫。我的意思是，社交媒体上可能会有关于《恋爱岛》变得“觉醒”的抱怨。我其实很清楚斯波鲁斯会发生什么。那是我唯一知道的。会发生什么？我觉得斯波鲁斯和拜伦会在一起。那奥林匹亚丝怎么办？留下奥林匹亚丝被抛弃并被踢出岛屿。因为如果你单身，你就无法生存。奥林匹亚丝被踢出岛屿。但等等，在这一点上，
at the point that Sporus jumps into bed with Byron. Yeah. I mean, in desperation, isn't she going to try and make a move on Judas or something? Or on Margaret Thatcher? I mean... Well, listen, we need to decide who our couples are katie so you need to decide so you are you booting olympias off and byron is pairing up with spores yeah yeah that's what i
在斯波鲁斯和拜伦上床的时候。是的。我的意思是，在绝望中，她难道不会试图去勾引犹大或者什么人吗？或者勾引玛格丽特·撒切尔？我的意思是……好吧，听着，我们需要决定我们的情侣是谁，凯蒂，所以你需要决定，所以你要把奥林匹亚丝踢走，然后拜伦和斯波鲁斯配对，是吗？是的，这就是我
know surely olympias would make a move on jimmy carter rather than francis stewart and and poor francis stewart is so dumb that she'd be powerless she'd wake up and find three enormous snakes in her bed and it would never cross her mind that someone was out to get her because she'd be powerless. She'd wake up and find three enormous snakes in her bed, and it would never cross her mind that someone was out to get her, because she'd be too dumb. Do you think Olympias would have things to talk about with Jimmy Carter? Yeah, Olympias is a woman with a hard-headed understanding of power. So I think that she'd be able to help Jimmy Carter with the energy crisis, and certainly she'd be able to help him with his running.
知道的，奥林匹亚丝肯定会去勾引吉米·卡特，而不是弗朗西斯·斯图尔特，而可怜的弗朗西斯·斯图尔特太笨了，她会无能为力。她醒来发现床上躺着三条巨大的蛇，她永远不会想到有人要对付她，因为她太无能了。她醒来发现床上躺着三条巨大的蛇，她永远不会想到有人要对付她，因为她太笨了。你觉得奥林匹亚丝和吉米·卡特会有共同话题吗？是的，奥林匹亚丝是一个对权力有清醒认识的女人。所以我认为她能够帮助吉米·卡特解决能源危机，而且她肯定能帮他处理竞选事务。
Oh, I like that. I like that. Okay. Byron and Sporus. Byron and Sporus. Byron and Sporus. And then let's go for Olympias and Jimmy Carter. And then let's get rid of Francis Stewart. And the rest are all as is. Yeah. Stanley Baldwin and Theodora.
哦，我喜欢这个。我喜欢这个。好吧。拜伦和斯波鲁斯。拜伦和斯波鲁斯。拜伦和斯波鲁斯。然后我们选奥林匹亚丝和吉米·卡特。然后我们把弗朗西斯·斯图尔特踢走。剩下的都保持原样。是的。斯坦利·鲍德温和西奥多拉。
Judas is still with Marcia. Yeah. I feel quite strongly about that. Wow. Okay. And then Custer and Lola. Yeah. Okay. So Katie. about that wow okay and then Custer and uh Lola yeah okay so Katie so let's so the five historical
犹大还是和玛西娅在一起。是的。我对此感觉很强烈。哇。好吧。然后是卡斯特和萝拉。是的。好吧。所以凯蒂。对此感觉很强烈，哇，好吧，然后是卡斯特和呃萝拉，是的，好吧，所以凯蒂，所以让我们，所以这五位历史上的
Love Island 2022 contestants are Lord Byron and Sporus, Jimmy Carter and Olympias, Stanley Baldwin and Theodora, Judas and Marcia Falkender, General Custer and Lola Montes. Now only four can go forward to the public vote. Which of those five couples are you going to evict? I think it might have to be Judas and Marcia Williams. Wow. That is a bombshell for Judas. That is a bombshell. He's gone back. He just can't win, can he?
《恋爱岛》2022年的参赛者是拜伦勋爵和斯波鲁斯、吉米·卡特和奥林匹亚丝、斯坦利·鲍德温和西奥多拉、犹大和玛西娅·福肯德、乔治·卡斯特将军和萝拉·蒙特斯。现在只有四对可以进入公众投票。你要淘汰这五对情侣中的哪一对？我觉得可能得是犹大和玛西娅·威廉姆斯。哇。这对犹大来说是个重磅炸弹。这真是个重磅炸弹。他回去了。他就是赢不了，对吧？
I mean, I just don't think people, I think people don't trust them. He was in it for the money and now nothing. And now nothing. Yeah, I think it was a bit transparent, maybe his motives. So the public didn't like it. So, ladies and gentlemen, that's the result. We will put this up to vote on Twitter. Byron and Sporus, Carter and Olympias, Baldwin and Theodora, Custer and Montez.
我的意思是，我只是觉得人们，我觉得人们不信任他们。他是为了钱才参加的，现在什么都没得到。现在什么都没得到。是的，我觉得他的动机有点太明显了。所以公众不喜欢。所以，女士们先生们，这就是结果。我们会在推特上进行投票。拜伦和斯波鲁斯、卡特和奥林匹亚丝、鲍德温和西奥多拉、卡斯特和蒙特斯。
Amazing. But there can be only one victor, only one winning couple, and it is up to you, the public, to decide. And so we will announce the result in a special bonus episode that we will put out in, what, a day after tomorrow.
太棒了。但只能有一个胜利者，只能有一对获胜的情侣，这取决于你们，公众来决定。所以我们将在一个特别的奖励剧集中宣布结果，我们会在，嗯，后天发布。
And we will go over the entrails, have a look, analyse the drama and crown our 2022 Historical Love Island champions. Thanks very much for listening. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye.
我们将回顾这些细节，看一看，分析其中的戏剧性，并加冕我们2022年历史版《恋爱岛》的冠军。非常感谢大家的收听。再见。再见。再见。
Thanks for listening to The Rest is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。如需奖励剧集、抢先收听、无广告收听以及进入我们的聊天社区，请在restishistorypod.com注册。网址是restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的来源，在我们的问答环节中，我们会揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、奖励剧集和抢先购买现场门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。网址是therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。